hello I'm Gavin welcome to this solo
hosted slo-mo guys video this video is
sponsored by LG and to help us make it
they've kindly provided this colossal
television which is currently displaying
the live feed of a phantom camera sat
right over there so why don't we take a
look at this out there is a set of
stills photos online by a German
photographer called Marcus Ruggles
I think it's how you pronounce his name
who's done a bunch of droplet
photography so as the droplet falls into
the water and then Rises back up and
separates from its column we'll take a
picture and it will refract an image
through the droplet behind so he's done
the earth and other planets and we're
going to basically replicate that but
have a video element so you can actually
see it in motion and hopefully see the
separation of the droplet and it'll just
look like the planet Earth has a little
globe in a tiny droplet of water now in
order to make this work
we need to flip the world upside down
and that is because the droplet of water
will be flipping the image so all of the
information down here will be seen in
the top of the droplet and all the
information from up here will be seen in
the bottom kind of like how your
eyeballs work now I didn't actually have
a big map of the earth by this so I
printed one out that's like 15 pieces of
paper cut them out and stuck them to
this board it looks pretty terrible but
hopefully because it all be seen through
a droplet about here you won't be able
to notice how shoddy my map is we'll
start at 12 and a half thousand frames a
second and the view 26:40 which means we
need a lot of light let me stop you down
there and this could take many many
attempts
because this is such a fiddly shot and
this camera is very loud to stand next
to you I'm gonna play it back on the 8k
ol it while we watch this back I'm going
to turn off the on-screen display so we
don't have anything fixed
so this time I focused on the droplet
itself yeah and it does seem like the
map is too far away from the droplet to
be in focus at the same time so I'm
gonna have to figure out a way to add
some depth here I do love how the 12000
frames the separation here should be
really really nice what do you think
Smee oh yeah do you like that that's
cool with it what do you think of the
droplet what do you think of the droplet
it's good innit yeah
this is the opposite the map is in focus
but the actual definition of the droplet
is very blurry
that one went a little bit too high just
out of frame so I'm just gonna tilt up
try again so stop the lens down here
that's why it's a lot darker but it has
brought this map slightly more in focus
I think I'm gonna have to stop the lens
down even further to get that sharp
looking which will make it even darker
but this is currently at 12,000 frames a
second and I think it might be slower
than we need god I love the way all the
way it stacks them like that so we could
probably get away with dropping it to
6,000 frames a second and stopping the
lens down even more where you set the
old syringe here so this is 6,000 frames
a second so we've gained an entire stop
of light and I've been able to add a
little bit more depth it's still dark so
I'm gonna add another light but this is
just testing it yeah so now the actual
droplet itself is showing sharpness as
well as the map getting there I want to
get just a bit more light now so I'm
going to turn on this very bright torch
which may result in an extremely bright
Africa now to my eye at the time this
one made the map look the sharpest I've
seen
definitely the cost of the sharpness of
the drop that I Wow
you can actually see how bad my map is
in this fund you'll see that lie at the
cost of even more speed I think I've got
the map and the droplet as sharp as I
want them at the same time we're only at
3,000 frames a second though so it is a
little bit briefer I still long enough
to see it or liking this
I really enjoy videos like this just
experimental ones where you can just
change one variable each time currently
the only light is on the map and I'm
wondering whether to get this to appear
a little bit more spherical in 3d I
should actually shine some light to give
all highlights on the edges of the
droplet so maybe hitting the droplet
with some light at some point might be
worth doing so now I've taken the light
that was blasting the top of Africa and
I've shined it directly on the droplet
so we'd have these glistening parts it
looks more like a marble Wow I'm not
sure if that's what we want but that's
definitely a different look not a huge
fan of all these glares it's putting it
I think for the next shot I'm gonna get
off this macro lens and I just pull back
slightly maybe get a shot at the glass a
bit of a wider shot and the map a little
bit more in focus so this will now allow
me just to be a little bit further back
see the whole fall of the droplet see
the crown see the column the separation
of the droplet and also the entire glass
and the map at the same time
it's a lot easier when it's not macro
back at 12,000 frames
you
yeah I feel like 12,000 is actually
pretty perfect for this it's incredibly
leisurely like it's not too slow but you
really do see everything that's
happening there and this has a lot more
context than the SuperDuper macro stuff
so far they're still in every shot
there's been sort of like a black border
and the whole thing and I think that's
mainly because my light is so close to
the map it's leaving very dark areas
which I kind of need the light to be
that close to those it's not intense
enough such the glaring error in this
shot the light that's lighting me over
there is not a high-speed light it's too
low power so it's flickering because of
the AC current and you can see it in a
reflection there that is as high speed
101 really i've ballsed it up next up
I'm going to take this lens off and the
mount off as well so it accepts a PLN's
one of these cinema lenses just a 200
mils so I'm going to put this on move
the camera really far back to its
minimum focus and what that should do is
bring the background and the droplet
closer together in the shot
perfect
Oh
never in my life at a monitor this [ __ ]
she's gonna top up the water a little
bit
get see can see stuff floating in it
so now I'd love to tell you a little bit
about this TV this is the world's first
LG signature 8k OLED TV it's 88 inches
diagonally which that's bigger than my
wings but I don't think you'll ever get
old that they used a screen shot from
one of our videos as the YouTube sign in
page on Android TVs
I literally just press YouTube and that
pop-up to put the resolution of a que
into perspective if this was an HD TV it
would be 1920 by 1080 pixels which is
about 2 megapixels and if it was UHD it
would be 3840 by 2160 which is about 8
megapixels this TV is 7680 by 4320 which
is about 33 megapixels every frame is 33
megapixels just for a laugh I've
connected a PC to it and I've set the
resolution to 76 80 by 4320 and it
currently has scaling of 300% which
makes everything look normal-sized I'm
just gonna set it to 100% because then
everything will be pixel for pixel at 8
K resolution which well that should be
comical to be honest see how big the
Start menu is you can honestly sit here
like this to do some work now you might
be wondering what can I watch in 8k on a
screen like this well let me show you
we've actually been shooting a lot of
our videos in 8k
for quite some time so you can watch our
videos if you want this one's available
in 43 20p 50 see how it looks
if my GP doesn't explode I can see the
bald spot on the top of my head that's
the downside of a que I guess in the
last TV video I was showing how an LCD
panel looked different to an OLED panel
under a macro lens this is what the 77
inch 4k OLED looked like under five
times magnification through the macro
lens and just to show the increased
pixel density this is the a.k 88 inch
OLED under five times magnification and
that just about does it hopefully you
enjoyed that footage big old thanks to
LG for sponsoring this video and do make
sure you subscribe to the slow mo guys
we have a second channel too I recommend
it